you have this Behavior pattern where you
snap you have this Behavior pattern
where you yell and you get upset and you
make people wrong and you don't mean to
if you are somebody who's ever said to
yourself I wish I could stop yelling or
I wish I could stop snapping this video
is absolutely unbelievable and the
reason why is I explain this research
that was so mind-blowing for me it's
called ghosts in the nursery a lot of
the patterns that you have that you
don't have control over are patterns
from your childhood and they are there
because when you were a kid you
experienced people in your life that
were tense did you ever have a parent
that was a Yeller
did you ever have a teacher that was a
yeller or a coach that was a yeller and
secretly in your little kid body
whenever your mom or dad would yell or
your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right you would feel nervous you
would feel on edge of course that's how
we all feel right well here's the reason
why you might have an issue like I used
to have an issue where I would yell at
my kids and then I'd feel terrible about
it I'd snap at my husband and then I'd
feel terrible about it psychologist and
then I would say to myself I'm not doing
that again I'm not doing that again but
I wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery it means that any situation
where you start to feel tense or you
start to feel stressed out guess what
happens your body remembers what it was
like when you were little to feel tense
and stressed out and what were the
adults doing around you when you felt
that way
they were snapping they were yelling and
now here you are repeating the pattern
and you don't know why and you feel
guilty
and I'm explaining this to you because
it wasn't until I thought holy cow like
I know I don't want to snap at my
husband I know I don't want to take my
anger from work out on my family why
can't I stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
anytime and when they were you felt
tense and stressed out so now that
you're an adult when you're tense and
stressed out you repeat the behavior
that you witnessed crazy right so how do
you stop it well the first step to
stopping anything is to actually
understand what you're dealing with
now that you know you're dealing with a
pattern now all you need to do is
basically say okay I'm going to put a
practice in place it's going to
interrupt this pattern what's the
practice well a really good one is
um before you walk in the house at the
end of the day if you're stressed out
Take Five
take five deep breaths like reset your
mood reset your energy before you walk
in the house and you'll be surprised by
how much nicer you are to the people
around you another thing that um that uh
you can do and this one's not so fun is
you can train your partner your kids
your roommates your family that if
you're trying to get a hold of how you
bring stress home you can train them to
say to you hey don't take your work
stress out on me when somebody that you
care about says that to you it's a
humbling experience and the person that
says it the most in my life is my son
Oakley your uh the youngsters seem to
love to cross-check the adults so be
careful with taking that advice
that negative voice inside your head
that's telling you that you suck and you
can't do it that's not your voice
that's not actually your voice that's
not you telling yourself that you suck
that voice was planted there that voice
was put there by somebody else in your
life and probably early on growing up
telling you that you can't do something
you were not born you didn't come out of
the womb and say I suck I can't do
anything no you're playing you're
experimenting you're finding Joy you're
laughing you're you're doing it
and then along the way people tell you
that you can't do it that you should
stop that you should quit that it's not
going to work out that you can't do it
and we've been so conditioned around
that that we take it on and we think
it's our voice
when you come up with an idea right
just Workshop this you come up with an
idea it's like I'm gonna I'm gonna go
I'm gonna write a book I'm gonna start a
YouTube channel I'm gonna launch this
business I'm going to whatever you come
up with your your bucket list your your
dream life your vision board you come
with a list of ideas things that you
think that you want to do things that
you
feel confident that you'd love to create
for yourself right okay what happens the
next day the next day
it's not even telling our friends you
know I think we we blame our friends and
say well we tell our friends and they're
going to be negative and and they they
crap on our idea and so we don't do it
well before that happens we crap on our
own ideas right you look at that list
the next day and say I can't do that who
who
who was I yesterday this crazy person
that I used to be yesterday who thought
I could do that
it's ourselves telling ourselves that we
suck but the problem is we've taken on
that voice and we think that it's us
that's not your voice that is not your
voice telling you that you suck that is
somebody else's voice that was planted
in your head that has been conditioned
to be there that we're so used to being
there that we have taken on as our voice
it has become your identity but it was
not your voice it was put there it was a
seed that was planted that has been
grown over time and you need to rip that
weed out
that is not your voice
you do not think that you suck
it's other people with low expectations
who hate their own lives who at some
point went and tried something that did
not work out for their life and now
nobody around them can have success
because it makes them look and feel bad
and so they spend their time ripping
other people down and apart
that's who planted that weed in your
head that might hit pretty hard I hope
it does because when that happened when
if you can actually
digest that
what ends up happening is you think oh
who whose voice is that who's whose
voice is in my head and that's great
awareness to know that it's not your
voice and then to identify whose voice
it is who told you these things who made
you feel this way growing up
and if you think about who that person
is if you can actually picture somebody
oh that was Uncle Joe or oh that was my
grade three teacher oh or that was my
you know the bully at school whoever
that person was now think about okay
it's that person's voice not you that's
already incredibly liberating
but then two do you want to live that
person's life like think about that
person probably they're not living a
great life they're not hitting their
potential they're not even happy with
what they're doing if somebody's
spending their day tearing other people
down what kind of painful life does that
person have to have when they go home
you don't want their life
if you don't want their life then you
definitely don't want their voice in
your head anymore
hopefully that creates an aha moment for
you that starts to actually shift things
because we've been so conditioned to
listen to that voice that we don't
recognize that we actually have a choice
to rip it out
and start to listen to our own voice
so that's step one step two then is
whatever you want more of in your life
you need to be surrounded by it more you
need to change the environment your
environment has been perfectly designed
to keep you where you are
and if you're watching this video I love
you thank you for being here you are
probably the happiest most optimistic
most positive most caring most pouring
into other people that's in your
environment if you think about you and
your friends and your family you're
you're the most optimistic person in
your family you're the most positive
person in your family you're the most
ambitious person in your family you're
the one who wants to care and serve the
most in your family right but
you know you're capable of way way more
right you know you can do way more than
what you're doing right now
and so you end up being this big fish in
a really tiny pond where you're serving
others and pouring into others and you
wish they could do more and that's
amazing don't stop caring for others but
you need more of a push yourself you
need to be around the people who are
doing things that you want to do on a
higher level
so the environment really matters in
your environment right now is is good
it's it's not terrible maybe it is
terrible but it's not great
most likely it's just good and it keeps
you stuck and it keeps you in slow
growth mode and it prevents you from
becoming the person that you actually
want to be so how do you start the shift
that will you shift your environment
and you may say well Evan I don't know
people who are super accomplished and
are living the life that I want to live
I don't have any of those friends if I
did I wouldn't be still stuck here and I
hear you I get it so the fastest way to
do it isn't through actually trying to
make those friends it's
through what I call aspirational mentors
it's by watching videos like this you
may never meet me you may never meet Mel
Robbins you may never meet whoever your
heroes are but you can learn from it
through these videos whoever you want
more of whoever you you respect and
maybe you're even jealous of that they
can think that way and live that way be
around them more
look at who you subscribe to on YouTube
look at who you subscribe to and follow
on Instagram look at the books you read
in a podcast you listen to and the shows
that you watch are they from the people
who make you feel better about yourself
and give you hope inspiration and
courage to go Live Your Dream and if not
then switch it out
switch it out
if you are watching YouTube and you just
found that you you wasted the last three
hours of your life
it's not YouTube's fault
it's your fault
you're subscribed and watching the wrong
videos
because there's a lot of positivity out
there if you close a YouTube session you
feel worse about yourself then you
subscribe to the wrong channels if
you're watching this video and feel
worse about yourself one I sincerely
apologize and two you should unfollow me
and go follow somebody that that makes
you feel more hopeful and Alive because
if you started your day with the thing
that made you feel hopeful alive bold
confident powerful things are possible
your life will change
but we need that external stimulus you
are a product of your environment you
have to have those people around you you
can have Elon Musk and Mel Robbins and
Tony Robbins and whoever pushing you
every day you can have them pushing you
every day
by consuming their content we just
happened to be enslaved
by
the things that are around us that we
haven't designed with intention that's
all yeah YouTube the algorithm is so
addictive
so addictive you you get one video that
then takes you down another path and
another path and now all of a sudden
you've just watched three hours of
videos on something that doesn't make
your life better you don't actually
really care about you just got sucked
into the drama of a certain storyline
has that ever happened to you
remember I watched the Michael Jordan
tribute the last dance and I went to
research
one of the story lines of Scottie Pippen
and Michael Jordan to see kind of what
the 2022 updated version was and all of
a sudden I got down this Rabbit Hole of
Scottie Pippen versus Michael Jordan and
three hours later there's still other
videos to watch like what am I doing
this is a waste of time I don't even
care that much about these guys
I watched the last dance it was a great
documentary and and I learned from it
and I love the drive and tenacity and
hustle but I don't care about the drama
between Michael Jordan and Scottie
Pippen and so we will easily default
back into that Comfort mode and back
into consuming drama
you have to with intention try to bring
that back
so here's a grid
homework assignment go look at your
YouTube homepage and see what's being
recommended to you and how many of those
videos whether it's my Channel or other
channels how many of those how many
videos on your home page right now will
make you a better human will make you
feel more proud of yourself will make
you feeling hopeful confident and
courageous ready to take some action on
some of your goals and how many of them
are drama how many of them are pure
entertainment how many of them you know
will lead to some giant rabbit hole that
you don't want to go down if you
actually set out your calendar and say
how do I want to spend my day with
intention how many of these videos would
actually lead you towards that path
right and for too many people it's it's
not a it's not a pretty picture
we're listening to the wrong people and
so you can change that
you know you could change that if we
Circle back you recognize that the
negative voice in your head is not your
voice it was planted there by somebody
else who hates their life and you don't
want their life
then you switch it to say okay well
whose life do I want and ultimately you
want your best version of your life but
to get there you're taking different
pieces from different people's lives
like oh I like how he does that and she
does that and and she does this and
you're pulling different people
different things from different people
and then you start to surround yourself
with that
and the shift doesn't happen overnight
but if you're constantly pouring these
people into you if you're constantly
pouring Evan Carmichael into you you're
gonna start to believe more on yourself
and if you're constantly pouring other
people into you you're gonna start
thinking like them behaving like them
taking on their mindsets and their
beliefs
and if those are beliefs that you want
and the mindset that you want amazing
you get to choose now
you're in control
you've been a product of your
environment your early environment with
negativity your ongoing environment with
probably just mediocrity keeping you
where you are and now you can change it
you can shift it you can decide to be in
a different spot one year from today
and the most important step you can do
is to start choosing and carefully
decide with intention who you want to be
around
so that in one year from now you are in
a different spot not just for you but so
you can serve others and lift them up to
catch up as well
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
I actually have an incredible quote of
yours about dreams you say when it comes
to your dreams you have two choices
pursue them or be haunted by them
it's true you can't forget a dream
you can
something that you want in your life
once you really want it and you give
yourself permission to feel that desire
there's something called the zygarnic
effect and the zygarnic effect is this
thing that happens in your brain and I
also think it's tied into your heart and
your nervous system but it happens in
your brain where when something is
important to you
and you can feel that wave hit you your
mind takes note and goes oh
I'm going to put this on the list in the
file of my mind called this is important
and whenever you are near anything
that's related to what's important to
you your mind changes the live Network
and filter of your brain will change in
real time to try to alert you
to the fact that you're near something
that is important to you and I'm not
making this up this has been proven in
study after study and
I think that's why your dreams haunt you
you can ignore them you can shove them
down you can tell yourself you don't
want it anymore
but if you've ever wanted something
deeply it doesn't leave you it gets
stored in the subconscious part of your
mind waiting for you to remember that
it's there and to get to work on it if
you've always dreamed of living in an
amazing beach house somewhere you you
will always think about it and you'll
either pursue it or you're going to be
haunted by it if you've ever thought
about taking your grandmother's recipe
and like doing something with that
tomato sauce you'll either pursue it or
it's going to haunt you and that's
because of how you're designed as a
human being
so you got two choices you either do
something about it or you're going to
live for the rest of your life with this
thing in the back of your mind that
slowly eats at you that the one person
the one person that is diminishing your
ability to make these dreams a reality
is you
because when you state your dream this
is what happens you state it and then
all of a sudden you're present to how
far away you are from it and when you
see the distance between where you are
and where you want to go the direction
that your dream requires you to walk in
you're going to get present to the Gap
and that scares us that's where fear
comes into play and you start to think
of all the reasons why you don't deserve
it you start to think of all the reasons
why you can't do it all that you have to
do in order to start to pursue your
dreams is take small actions every day
that align your life in that direction
so what does that mean if you want to
play guitar professionally it means that
you start playing Guitar more it means
that you sign up for Open Mic nights it
means that you go back to class if if
that's something that interests you you
see your dreams will happen either
because of you or in spite of you they
don't happen because of other people
they happen because of you and what you
do
the second you have The Bravery to state
that dream now are you going to create
it or are you going to diminish it in
your mind those of us that are out there
in the world doing big things that one
of the reasons why we're able to do big
things is because we have trained
ourselves to just push forward even when
things are not the way that you want
them to be going to keep your cool to
um roll with the punches even when you
don't have the support that you need and
so uh you know I had something happen
yesterday I was in the middle of giving
a speech so imagine this you're on stage
you are 20 minutes into your speech you
have 40 more minutes to go you have 30
more slides to go to which is what uh
was happening at that point and all of a
sudden my laptop dies
I mean just blank you guys so I've got
an entire audience
I'm through the first third of my speech
I Have two-thirds of the speech to go
and my speech is a story that has a ton
of of uh videos and and photos in it and
my laptop died
and what had happened is the AV team had
plugged the laptop into a Podium that
had no power in it so my laptop was set
up correctly it was plugged in but it
was plugged into something that had
absolutely no power source so over the
course of the hour before the tech check
to when I was on the stage the laptop
has run out of juice and so all of a
sudden
here I am completely cold laptop I just
you know had this moment where I thought
the first thing in my mind was holy cow
what am I going to do for the next 40
minutes
and I could feel my stomach start to go
crazy and the butterflies to kick in and
um it just wow
um I was I was extremely
panicked for about a second and then I
was like okay use the tools
use the tools don't don't get nervous
get excited because you can show
everybody what looks like in front of a
live audience to have a massive
technical breakdown and not lose your
cool and so I made a joke about it the
AV team ran up I said look you guys have
no power here so take it back there get
it plugged in and I'll talk for two or
three minutes while you get this thing
set up now meanwhile I'm thinking
while I'm talking to a live audience
what if they don't get this set up what
am I going to do how am I going to fill
the 40 minutes when the whole speech is
not only anchored in the story but it's
anchored in all of these photographs and
proof of people's stories from around
the world and so I'm like don't panic
Don't Panic use the tools Mel and then
all of a sudden the guy shouts out
what's your password you know because my
my screen was locked so then I thought
okay we're going to get this done not a
problem it took about five minutes for
things to get back up and running and it
was one of the longer five minute
periods of my life but I got through it
and one of the reasons why I got through
it is because I've trained myself to
roll with the punches that's what I've
trained myself to do Heather
um is held back at work because what
happens is when she has to have a really
difficult conversation when there's
something that she wants to talk to her
boss about when there's a conflict with
one of her colleagues you ever have a
conflict with your colleagues at work
ever feel like you work in a toxic work
and environment well this is something
that you need to understand
sometimes the toxicity in your work
environment is about the other people
and sometimes the toxicity in your work
environment or in your life environment
or your friend environment is about
stored memories in your body from your
childhood I know it's crazy stuff
because the saying Feel the fear and do
it anyway it's true because your body
feels situations that set you uh
that puts you in a state of being afraid
before your mind catches up and starts
thinking about what you're afraid of and
so one of the key takeaways from take
control and one of the things that I
want to teach you today is that if you
start to tune into your body and you
start to notice the signals that your
body is sending to you in your
day-to-day life signals like butterflies
in your stomach signals like feeling A
Rush of energy up to your neck signals
like your armpit sweating signals like
your hands getting sweaty signals that
your body is stepping and noticing a
situation that reminds it of your past
learning how to read those signals that
oh my God here goes my body my body is
starting to recognize that this is a
situation that puts me on edge
recognizing those signals first and
slowing the body response down before
your brain starts to go oh my God oh my
God oh my God oh my God God that is a
critical skill in taking control of your
life everything we talk about has to be
proven right everything I love that I
don't give you some I've read in a book
or something that I've read on Instagram
the only things that we share are things
that are backed by science that have
been researched that we have seen
working in our own lives that we see
working for our audience and I think
that is critical because let's face it
anybody can put up a inspirational quote
you know that they've read from somebody
else anybody can tell you to you know be
positive or do this or put in the work
or hustle or whatever the hell it may be
at the end of the day it's just talk
yeah you have to know how yeah and I
also am you know somebody who is a
little bit cynical
so you know I'm sort of embarrassed that
I'm in self-help on some level because
it sounds stupid right you know I mean I
come from I I mean I I'm older than you
I'm almost 50. self-help had a really
bad name 20 years ago and I also am ivy
league lawyer yeah and I
um am an entrepreneur there's a lot of I
mean there's a lot of there's a lot of
fake people out for sure I I have are
renting houses and Ferraris and telling
you if you use their click funnel
strategy or whatever strategy that
you'll be rich like they are and yeah
you may and Chase the money if it
energizes you but there's a lot of smoke
in there for many of us slowing down is
really scary but that's exactly what you
need to do and so if you are always in a
rush if you feel like there's urgency in
your life if you move at a pace that
makes you feel panicked or rushed you
got a million things to do and you think
that you're busy but you're not
productive the solution is not doing
more it's doing less it's not speeding
up it's actually slowing down because
being busy doesn't mean you're in
control it means you're being driven by
this fear of slowing down you're being
driven by the fear that when you slow
down you're going to have to confront
where you're at and you're gonna have to
start doing the work and that'd be that
could be scary
but you take control of your life not by
speeding up everybody but by slowing
down you take control of your life by
removing distraction and adding in Focus
you take control of your life by being
honest with yourself about the things
that you're filling your life with that
doesn't matter that makes you so busy
and that also prevents you from finding
the 15 minutes that you need every day
to really find the courage to focus on
making your life a little bit better or
pushing something forward if you're
somebody who's guilty of being busy and
never having the time to do the thing
that really matters to you that your
heart's calling you to do or you never
have the time to do something to take
care of yourself I want you to find 15
minutes today
and I want you to slow down
whether you've always thought about
meditating and you've never done it
download the com map
listen to it do one guided meditation go
for a walk for 15 minutes just a quiet
walk without your phone or with your
phone turned off
uh have a cup of tea or a cup of coffee
and read something listen to a podcast
for 15 minutes take a bath tonight
something where you experience the
sensation of slowing down
because again busyness becomes a habit
and when it becomes a habit it becomes
an epidemic and when it becomes an
epidemic it will rob you of your ability
to take control of your life and at the
root cause of all of this is fear just
the fear of slowing down because when
you slow down and you start to create
priorities and you start to take control
now you're responsible for what's
happening in your life and you can no
longer rely on just complaining that
you're busy I think the most important
thing I want you to know is whatever it
is that you're dealing with right now
how scary it is no matter how
overwhelming it is
or even if you're just bored with where
your life is or if you're super happy I
want you to know that you always have
the power to change your life because
you have the power to make a decision to
change how you think about something to
change how you treat the people around
you to draw boundaries and to make the
small changes that add up to absolutely
everything you gotta raise your own game
gotta raise your own game and so what is
the game that you play at work you got
to get out of the head that it's all
about you
the best team members are always
thinking about how to make the team
better the best team members are loyal
to the team the best people to work with
are the ones that are in it together and
so in order for you to get your toxic
colleague to shift Behavior you got to
model it and here's the interesting
thing about the research when people are
working with co-workers or on a team
where people collaborate and where you
have honest conversations it creates
what we call psychological safety which
basically just means I feel safe working
with you I know that if I come to you
with feedback you listen I know that if
I tell you how your behavior is
impacting me you'll actually care I know
that if you need help you'll come to me
and I know if I need help I can come to
you that's what psychological safety
means you're a safe person and hopefully
a fun person to work with so you've got
to model that that means you got to ask
for support that means you've got to
have direct collaborate or direct
conversations and it means you got to
support your team members too and do you
realize
that when you work with other people
that do this team members are 35 times
more likely to show visible commitment
to your success and they're 47 percent
more likely when you model it to work
hard to build and maintain your trust
so don't ever get resigned in thinking
that the way that you behave won't
impact how somebody else is behaving
around you one of the most important
things when you're in a situation where
the truth the facts are that there is
more on your plate than one human being
can effectively handle on his or her own
there's a really important moment where
you have to surrender
to the chaos that your life is for the
next couple weeks things are going to
change when summer hits
but part of what I find personally
is that when I resist and I do resist I
resist what's actually happening when
that's not the way that I want things to
go and so if you
start complaining or you start bringing
extra weight to all of the things that
are going on it's gonna make it feel
even more overwhelming and if you can
bring a sense of realism to it so I call
this and I think Sean anchors the one
that came up with this this this term
realistic optimism
realistic optimism is a really powerful
mindset because
you're not just putting a sunny spin on
a crappy situation
you're being realistic about where you
are in your life right now
and you are still
maintaining an optimistic point of view
and what that means is that you when
you're an optimist you believe that your
actions and your thoughts matter
you believe that you can handle what's
on your plate you believe that based on
your thoughts and your actions you can
positively affect the outcome of
whatever it is that you're dealing with
whether it's being wildly overwhelmed
because you're a single parent or
terrified because you just got a scary
Health diagnosis or you're spinning
because somebody just told you they
don't want to be in a relationship with
you anymore whatever it is that you're
facing that's making you feel
overwhelmed
first start with how important it is to
be a realistic optimist so there's a
surrendering to what's so but you're
going to stay very optimistic and
positive and know that everything that
you think and do is in your control and
that when you know that your behavior
matters it gives you a sense of
empowerment that's proven by research
super duper important it's also why you
can have a very hard life right now and
a very overwhelming life right now and
still be happy
because you know based on being a
realistic Optimist that this period will
pass and you know that there are things
that you can think about and do that are
within your control often times when you
hit bottom you bounce
and that's where I think the power is
that you when the world feels upside
down you always have the power to make
it right when one chapter ends you
always have the power to write a new one
when you know you feel like nobody loves
you you have the power to learn how to
love yourself and if there's one thing
that covid-19 has done regardless of
whatever Devastation it has caused in
your life is it has forced us all to
experience the great pause
and I read that in a medium article and
I loved that idea of a pause because I
think in 2020 our lives have gotten so
fast and so digital and when you are
forced to pause and get present and to
slow down you are reminded of what's
actually important
and what's important is your health
what's important is your family and your
friends what's important is whether or
not you are taking care of yourself and
thinking positive thoughts versus
negative thoughts the world gave us a
gigantic experiment where we got to
practice and get to continue to practice
the most important skill in the planet
which is emotional resilience the
ability to face hard
and actually be okay the ability to face
the uncertain and redirect your
attention on things that you know that
are certain but as is the case in life
you're always going to be growing and
when you hit new chapters in your life
it's really important to be deliberate
and mindful about the people that you
spend time with and who you surround
yourself with does that mean you got to
ditch your high school friends
absolutely not
but it might mean that you shouldn't
spend as much time with them it might
mean that you should show up to those
friendships a little bit differently and
maybe they'll go a little bit deeper and
it definitely means that based on where
you are in your life right now that you
should get more proactive about
surrounding yourself with a group of new
friends or current friends that are up
to the same kind of growth that you are
why do you think that is in human beings
that you know if things are going bad we
won't change if they're going good we
won't change but it's almost like we
need a massive breakdown near-death
experience divorce covid for us to see
clearly to start changing
there's a really simple answer patterns
earn
s
and if you feel stuck or broken I
guarantee you while you feel that way
you're not you have a pattern of
behavior or a pattern of thinking that
is broken and we need to be disrupted
because we love our patterns and even
people that I know like
even when we're in Pain's familiar for a
lot of people yeah so a lot of people
like you may be listening to Lewis and I
talking and you grew up in a super
chaotic household maybe your parents
argued all the time maybe your Dad or
Mom were in and out maybe there was a
lot of fighting maybe there was actual
abuse I don't know what was going on but
it was chaotic as hell and so as an
adult you have vowed yourself you're not
going to repeat that pattern but what
ends up happening is because as a little
kid you observed witness absorbed the
pattern of Chaos in your nervous system
unless you go about the intentional work
of breaking the pattern of Chaos
you will create it in your own life
because it's what's familiar
you won't understand why do I keep
dating these why do I why do I go to
these bosses that treat me like crap
because you don't know what it feels
like
to be in a relationship with either a
boss or a romantic partner or a roommate
that is consistent because for the first
18 years of your life you lived in a
state called when's the next shoe going
to drop right and so wherever it is in
your life that something is broken there
is a pattern That You Don't See yet that
is making you continue to stay in a
broken situation it's all that thinking
that overthinking that thinking too big
thinking big is about dreams thinking
big is about goals thinking big is about
your heart and your soul and figuring
out what you want then once you do that
and you think big and you see where
you're headed boom you got to come back
and you've got to go Brick by Brick to
make that Vision stick you got to go
Brick by Brick to make the action stick
you gotta go Brick by Brick to lay that
pathway forward and to keep going and
let me tell you something I don't care
how busy you are I don't care how tired
you are I don't care how much there is
to do to make this big dream forward you
have time to lay one brick a day you
really do you really do and this is the
secret everybody this is the secret to
everything it's to understanding that
there is no timeline to getting your
dreams done
all there is to do is to allow your
heart and soul to dream big to see the
path forward and then to pull yourself
into the moment every day and have the
discipline to be deliberate to lay one
brick on that path that's it and to keep
reminding yourself that everything that
you're learning on the way is you lie
bricks down and you move forward a
little at a time is helping you build
the path and there will be times that
you start to lay bricks in this
direction and you realize whoa wait a
minute I'm going over here and my dream
is over there I guess I better lay
bricks over here and head back in the
direction then you're going to go this
way that's great because everything that
you learned over here is going to be
exactly what you needed in order to be
doing what your big dream is having a
breakdown is one of the biggest things
on the planet because what you get is
you get a break from your own
and you can look objectively at where
you are and for the first time look
ahead and say well what do I want to go
create and nine times out of ten if
you're discouraged right now if you've
got Financial Devastation if you've if
you're facing something that is making
this moment in time as hard for you as
life was for Lewis and I in 2008 during
the last recession I beg you
ask yourself honestly if what you had is
actually what you wanted the thing that
you just lost that that job that you
bitched about all the time that
relationship that was yeah to you yeah
yes or the friends you can't hang out
with because it's convenient and you
can't you're in quarant like actually
ask yourself if this is what you wanted
or were you just used to it um
being used to something Louis I think is
the biggest reason why people don't
change
I asked my mother I love my mother I
love my parents I've been married 51
years which is a feat because they were
my mom was a Teen Mom but
uh I asked her once if she'd go to a
personal development center I would
think what'd you say
are you [__] kidding me
why would I want to change at my age oh
wow I might discover
my life
wow
I was like okay I'm just gonna leave
that right there right and I always talk
about how you have the power in your
life always I know that you may have
your feelings hurt I know you may be
angry or upset or frustrated I certainly
feel those things all the time in my
life but I want you to understand that
no matter what's going on you always
have the power because you can choose
what you think and what you do next
you may not be able to control the way
that somebody treated you you may not be
able to control uh the number of
promotions that have passed you by you
may not be able to control whether or
not your boss is a jerk face or not to
you but you can choose how you respond
to these things and that's where your
power is and this is a very important
first piece of advice by the way is that
a lot of times we start to feel the
weight of the overwhelm but we don't get
out of our heads and if you spend too
much time thinking about all the stuff
that's going on and you don't go through
the process of breaking it down and
figuring out what actually is important
to you and prioritizing what you're
going to do about it you're just going
to continue to feel heavier and heavier
and heavier it's more and more sunk I
mean it's it's very very difficult thing
to feel why don't you like the size you
are
is it yes okay because I don't believe
in losing weight to be skinny I believe
in getting healthy because of how it
makes you feel yeah so if you love the
size that you are and it's healthy you
should stay the size that you are oh but
if you look in the mirror and seeing
your body the size that it is gives you
evidence to say I'm a piece of [__] or
I'm unworthy what do you say to yourself
when you see yourself in the mirror
tell me what is it
outside of your head
let's bring it to the light because you
know you feel comfortable saying this to
yourself
when you're alone don't you I want you
to say it out loud because it's it's not
okay to say this stuff to yourself what
do you say to yourself that we're not
going to say anymore I'm disgusting what
else
I hate the way that I look I hate that I
feel I hate the way that I feel okay
what do you want what do you deserve to
feel good when they walk down this to
you yes yes you do see I think at the
heart of this I think at the heart of
this is a belief
that you don't deserve to feel that way
so who taught you to feel this that you
don't deserve it when did you start
saying that to yourself that you don't
deserve it Holly
that's usually when it happens
so what I want you to do is I want you
to leave here and what you're going to
go to war against is not your weight
you're going to go to war against the
pattern in your head okay because the
longer you invalidate yourself the less
motivated you're going to be to change
yeah because you're beating yourself
down so we got to start with not fixing
you you're not broken you're perfect how
you are holly you are
I know you don't feel that way but I
feel that way yeah it's the pattern up
here
that's broken yeah so we just want you
to have a zero tolerance policy for this
like I'm not worth it I don't deserve it
I'm a piece of this I'm all that no
54321 it's like an ax you got that and
then you're gonna come up what can we
say instead I can do this I do that I
can do this but more important I think
it needs to be more heart centered I
deserve
to feel good yeah I deserve
to have what I want watch me go get it
first of all you're not in a race so
there's no catching up and I want you to
stop saying you need to catch up with
everybody right now whether you're
facing this issue at work because you
haven't been promoted or you're facing
this issue because you're the only one
of your girlfriends who's not engaged or
married or pregnant or a mom yet or if
you're facing this issue because you
feel like you look around and you're
comparing your life to somebody else's
stop that stop that stop that stop that
it is one of the most horrible things
that you can do because it's very
demotivating because what you're doing
is you're making yourself wrong for
where you are and that's not going to
make you motivated what I want you to do
is see the Gap and recognize that if
you're jealous it's because you want
that thing
that's why my own mind because it's not
something I'm used to yet is making up
stories to cling to the old way of life
this is a moment in time everyone please
this is the greatest gift the greatest
gift is this moment of pause where you
get in touch with what you actually want
and if you don't have the skills
for crying out loud look around and take
an online course because if you need
skills to prepare yourself for the thing
that you want get them right now when
you hit a moment in your life or your
work or your family where you feel very
overwhelmed
one of the most important things to not
do is to not speed up
I tend to be the kind of person that
when I get overwhelmed or I feel the way
to the World on my shoulders or I feel
stuck I tend to start running into a
brick roll head first at about 50 miles
an hour
that is exactly what you should not do
you should slow down
you should slow down and you should
assess where you are and you should
bring that realistic optimism
to doing some problem solving and some
planning and some decluttering in your
very busy life in four through four main
categories okay it's so important that
you slow down and realize that part of
the overwhelm is coming from the fact
that you are too busy there is too much
on your plate there's probably a lot on
your plate that's the wrong things there
are probably things that you're thinking
about that are not important and that's
why once you slow down you also start to
think about being a realistic Optimist
you also need to declutter and that's
where your friend Mel Robbins comes in
setting a quitting time isn't something
that I invented it's something I stole
from a professor at Caltech and the the
setting and quitting time habit is so
important it leverages something called
Parkinson's law Parkinson's law is a
phenomenon around time that basically
says this
anything that you have to get done you
will get done in the amount of time that
you give to it so let me just ask you
this if you think about your to-do list
if you have 10 hours today to work on it
how long is it going to take you to get
through it 10 hours if you have 10
minutes to get through the to-do list
that you have how long is it going to
take you 10 minutes because the things
you need to do expand or contract
according to how much time you have to
give to it and so what I want you to do
right now because part of your problem
with your routine is you don't have one
you allow work to bleed into your
evening you allow work to just
constantly show up whenever the email
arrives and you're the one that has to
hit reset on your routine so that you
don't allow your work to do that when a
manager or a boss defines Norms the team
is 73 times more likely to work hard to
keep them and here's the kicker there
are 125 times more likely to address the
situation if there's somebody on the
team who is not operating within the
norms
you know I it's it's so obvious I mean
think about it if somebody were to walk
in
to work
and put their feet up on the desk and
turn on porn
and be sitting at their desk watching
porn would that be the norm
for your workplace I don't think so
unless you're working for Playboy or
you're working in the porn industry that
would be so out of the norm that
everybody would address it immediately
period full stop
and what I want you to understand is
that when you take responsibility for
how you're acting on the team and you're
collaborative and you're supportive and
you're putting the team first and you're
modeling that behavior and when you also
bring the courage and you dare as brene
Brown says to be brave enough to have
honest conversations with your
colleagues about what's acceptable and
what's not based on how things are
impacting you you personally shift the
culture in a positive direction now
here's a trick about gratitude writing
down what you're grateful for doesn't
work unless you do it this way because
if you if I ask you what you're grateful
for everybody says the same thing I'm
grateful to be alive I'm grateful for my
health and I'm grateful for my family
and that's so generic that you're not
retraining your brain right you've got
to add in the because
I'm grateful for X because and the added
detail will make you change up
what you say and it will also train your
mind in a way that's more detailed so it
actually has a lasting impact on the way
that you view the world
because you identify and for me as a kid
for whatever reason I have my own
version of feeling invisible and feeling
like I'm not good enough and so my way
of coping both with my anxiety and being
a survivor of sexual abuse and
um
and wanting love which we all need is I
was like an overachiever and so I'm the
kind of person that's super busy and a
go-getter because it got me attention
and if I was the one that was super busy
and achieving I not only got praise but
it also insulates you from other people
not picking you because you're the one
in a leadership role doing the picking
right and so there's a part of me at the
age of 51 that is realizing that you
know this these feelings of feeling
unworthy and this hyper drive to try to
achieve it's all coming from a place of
feeling inadequate or like what I'm
doing is not enough and so that's 50
having a talk show having a best-selling
book having the audible Originals having
the platform everywhere having the
impact is still don't feel being the
most booked female speaker in the world
like you still don't feel so stupid it's
annoying and human beings are annoying
we are stuck with this wiring like if
you think about it like all of the crap
you believe is probably a hangover from
age zero to ten
that as adults we walk around thinking
the same stuff we thought as kids and I
can't stand that I feel that way but
knowing it it allows me to catch it
before it has me before it stops me from
having an event or writing that next
book or taking a risk here's the thing
about morning routines I think morning
routine Envy is a real thing and I do
believe that a lot of people lie about
their morning routines I think lying
about your morning routine is a real
thing I think pretending you have the
perfect morning routine is a real thing
I'm
I'm about when I'm home I'm almost 80
percent in my morning routine I get it
done because it's super simple right so
I mean I think I need a simple one yes
and when I'm traveling
I almost never get the whole thing done
because there's too many excuses and so
I think the key to having a morning
routine and morning routines are
critical because how you start your day
has a massive proven impact on how your
day turns out there's one piece of
research that I think is really profound
and this comes from Sean anchor I talked
about this yesterday but I'm going to
tell you
um this too Susie if you consume three
minutes just three minutes of negative
news
of negative television of negative
emails maybe stressful emails from work
or stressful texts from friends you have
more than a 50 chance eight hours later
to say you had a bad day
and the reason why is because of what
consuming that kind of information does
to your mind it literally sets your mind
up to be on the lookout for things going
wrong and so the reason why a morning
routine is is actually so important is
because number one it determines what
your priority for the day is
and we also know based on Research that
your mood in the morning it impacts your
productivity all day long everything
that I have done since since we launched
the five second rule book was in
reaction to things that were coming to
me
so I never sat out and said hey the five
second rule audiobook has been a
complete uh like record breaker we
clearly have an audio audience let's go
pitch audible audible came to me which
is fantastic
um I never I always dreamed about having
a talk show but I wasn't out pitching
one
Sony came to me in fact the only reason
why we got into courses online courses
and we now have more than a half a
million people that have taken our
courses online
um
was because Success magazine came to me
and said let's do a course together
remember I was there interviewing you
for it oh and I was I hated it because
what I discovered is I hate being told
what to do and so but that gave me the
idea oh we should do courses ourselves
and so this pauses made me stop and go
what do I really want to do
and the the truth is I want to go and
make the biggest possible impact that I
can and I want to collaborate with more
people yeah and I want to do events
um and I
I don't want to be the CEO I'm a
terrible leader horrible leader the
worst actually
um because I'm amazing at coaching I'm
amazing at uh creating I'm amazing at
reacting I'm terrible at managing people
I am terrible at managing a project I
have ADD I have dyslexia
um I'm a bulldozer when I get anxious
um
we kill each other if we were roommates
or business partners but but I think
understanding yourself
is really important and so there's a
couple things that I've decided number
one I'm going to consciously create the
next chapter and what is that and
um well I'm still in the middle of doing
it yeah but you wasn't Advanced you want
to do these things you're talking about
yeah yes
and I wanna I wanna collaborate more
with a y
EP I don't want it to just be me I want
to build a
platform based business that uh reaches
more people because here's the thing
that has got that got me through kind of
the loss of the talk show and the way
that I think about things that I hope
helps
um if you're listening you're kind of
struggling with something
I believe and I went into the talk show
saying this to myself because
the story of people that have tried to
have a daytime talk show that was going
to fail
and
I went in there saying
this I'm not doing this because I expect
to have a successful talk show I'm going
to put a thousand percent into it so
that I have no regrets and I wouldn't
change a thing
but I'm going into this because I know
that there is a skill a person or an
experience I am meant to have
that will help me
for the next chapter that I can't see
coming one thing that's true about life
is that things are always changing
around you always whether you are moving
into a new season or in in school and
all of a sudden your kids school
schedules change or you're moving into a
new season of work and all of a sudden
your work life is changing or you're
moving into a new season of your
marriage or of your health or of
anything life changes all the time which
is why it's really important to be
self-aware and to make the small changes
that help you enjoy and seize all the
opportunities from the season of Life
work family relationships that you're in
right now the only thing that you can do
is change yourself for the better and
hope that that means that when you
change for the better that your friends
and the people that you love and care
about are inspired
and encourage change for the better too
and if you have people in your life that
are stuck they probably are all resigned
they don't believe that their behavior
can change this they don't believe that
their attitude can change this maybe
they're feeling a little beaten down
it's really hard to acknowledge the fact
that your lives are no longer synced up
but you gotta train yourself to look for
the positive
that she still loves you that she is
there for you and you've got to find new
ways to hang out that's it that's it and
here's the other thing you got to go to
work on you you got to start reaching
out and finding other friends to fill
your life you got to start investing in
yourself in order to pursue the things
that are interesting to you I think this
is the work that we all have to do every
single one of us whether you bulldoze
whether you people please whether you
avoid conflict whether you're impulsive
whether you uh yo-yo your decisions
whatever it is that is your pattern you
know you the the constant trashing
yourself I think the the the Journey of
your whole life is figuring out how to
truly like and love yourself if you are
afraid of disappointing people
if you're afraid that you're not good
enough you may catch that in one area of
your life but as your life gets bigger
and as you change it'll creep in in
other areas and one way that those
patterns where you don't think you
deserve it or you don't think you're
good enough or you're terrified of
disappointing people comes into play is
when you start to expect the worst
oh catch it that's the first step you
can't break the pattern unless you see
it and then you're going to replace it
and what I'm going to start doing is
I've got this little app on my watch you
can set it on your phone where every
like three hours it reminds me to
breathe and I noticed the second that
the alarm goes off I've been holding my
breath and so you can set a little alarm
in your phone Megan's laughing you can
set a little alarm in your phone that
just says Savor it's a reminder to take
a minute you can make it say take a
minute take a minute
around comp your complement yourself on
what's going right because expecting the
worst is something you taught yourself
to do guess what you can teach yourself
to take a minute and to savor what's
going right and the more you force
yourself to do it the more it'll become
a habit it comes back to the core
message that I always have for you no
matter what's happening around or to you
you hold the power
because you always have the power to
have an honest conversation you always
have the power to discuss how things are
impacting you you always have the power
to make requests and you certainly have
the power to draw boundaries and you
also have the power by the way if the
culture gets worse and worse or you just
are tired of it because it's not
changing to go find a different job
the power is always in you and I think
that's something that's so important to
constantly remind yourself I get that I
don't like where I am but what could I
do to change it
how can I change how I think about this
and I'm telling you right now you know
this the second you start changing how
you think about a situation the
situation changes the second you start
changing how you think about what your
options are you start to see them the
second you stop thinking that you're
stuck or that you're a victim and you
start thinking about how you solve
something you start to see Solutions and
so the answer is always in you if you
look at human development we're the only
species that literally can't survive
without another human being taking care
of you and so we are biologically
hardwired to bond with other people and
that is the ver from the very beginning
of when you come out
bonding with somebody else and making
sure they pay attention to you is your
survival imperative so you are born
meeting somebody else and I think what
ends up happening is there's never that
kind of clean break or pass off between
needing your parents to take care of you
needing your friend's approval to fit in
to truly having ownership over giving
yourself what you didn't get giving
yourself what you needed and that's the
piece that I've been doing a lot of
during the the great pause is slowing
down because so much of my busyness was
fueled by uh you know praise me love me
am I doing enough you know please tell
me I'm doing okay okay I can breathe now
I'm okay now
and when I slow down and maybe it's a
function of the anxiety that's when
things get scary because that's when
you've really got to be with yourself
the reason why it's so important to
start with a friend cleanse and I'm sure
a lot of you how many of you heard that
you thought oh my God getting rid of
people oh boy oh boy I'm gonna cleanse
these friends yes and no
a friend cleanse is critical because the
single most influential thing around you
are the people that you hang out with
and if you have relationships that are
toxic if you have relationships that
cause guilt if you have relationships
that are creating drama in your life if
you have relationships that are not
Equitable guess what that's creating the
overwhelm that's creating unhappiness
that's
keeping you doubting yourself if you
have friends that um have bad habits
guess what that's making it really
really hard for you to change your
habits for the good you have this
Behavior pattern where you get angry you
have this Behavior pattern where you
snap you have this Behavior pattern
where you yell and you get upset and you
make people wrong and you don't mean to
if you are somebody who's ever said to
yourself I wish I could stop yelling or
I wish I I I I I could just snap I could
stop snapping
this video is absolutely
unbelievable okay and the reason why is
I explain this research that was so
mind-blowing for me
it's called ghosts in the nursery a lot
of the patterns that you have that you
don't have control over are patterns
from your childhood
and they are there because when you were
a kid you experienced people in your
life that were tense did you ever have a
parent that was a Yeller
did you ever have a teacher that was a
yeller or a coach that was a yeller and
secretly in your little kid body
whenever your mom or dad would yell or
your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right you would feel nervous you
would feel on edge of course that's how
we all feel right well here's the reason
why you might have an issue like I used
to have an issue where I would yell at
my kids and then I'd feel terrible about
it I'd snap at my husband and then I'd
feel terrible about it psychologist and
then I would say to myself I'm not doing
that again I'm not doing that again but
I wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery
it means that any situation where you
start to feel tense or you start to feel
stressed out guess what happens your
body remembers what it was like when you
were little to feel tense and stressed
out and what were the adults doing
around you when you felt that way they
were snapping they were yelling and now
here you are repeating the pattern and
you don't know why and you feel guilty
and I'm explaining this to you because
it wasn't until I thought holy cow like
I know I don't want to snap at my
husband I know I don't want to take my
anger from work out on my family why
can't I stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
and when they were you felt tense and
stressed out so now that you're an adult
when you're tense and stressed out you
repeat the behavior that you witnessed
crazy right so how do you stop it well
the first step to stopping anything is
to actually understand what you're
dealing with now that you know you're
dealing with a pattern now all you need
to do is basically say okay I'm going to
put a practice in place that's going to
interrupt this pattern what's the
practice well a really good one is
um before you walk in the house at the
end of the day if you're stressed out
take five take five deep breaths like
reset your mood reset your energy before
you walk in the house and you'll be
surprised by how much nicer you are to
the people around you another thing that
um that uh you can do and this one's not
so fun is you can train your partner
your kids your roommates your family
that if you're trying to get a hold of
how you bring stress home you can train
them to say to you hey don't take your
work stress out on me when somebody that
you care about says that to you it's a
humbling experience and the person that
says it the most in my life is my son
Oakley your uh the youngsters seem to
love to cross-check the adults so be
careful with taking that advice I know
that in this next chapter that I
consciously create I want to have more
fun I want to I Really Wanna Love the
process yeah I don't want to make it so
hard on myself and be gripping
everything so tight and it's really easy
for me to see it in other people because
I know what it feels like in here I'm
working hard to break the patterns that
still hold me back and the big one that
holds me back is bulldozing that's the
it's it's it's literally when I start to
feel any level of tension this is
particularly true in my marriage I'm
married to a saint thank God Chris
Robbins meditates every morning it's the
only reason why we've lasted 26 years
shall he puts up with me when I feel my
like whatever emotion rise I immediately
raise my voice it's how I assert power
in the relationship
and I am so committed Louis to
breaking that pattern wow and being a
more fun person to be around and a
Kinder person to be around first of all
stop talking about passion
talking about launching a business okay
if you're lucky and you're in a position
where your bills are getting paid and
you have the luxury of being able to try
to think about what you want to do in
this next chapter
um here's where I want you to start I
want you to start with what energizes
you and how ironic is that given that
I'm speaking at the energetic Women's
Conference here in Indianapolis today
why am I saying energized and what do I
talk what am I talking about when I say
energized when I say energizes you I'm
asking you what is it that you're
curious about why is it that you feel so
expanded you feel energized you feel
kind of excited whenever you're doing it
you're in a phase when you're just
trying to figure out what's your next
move of just paying attention to your
curiosity paying attention to the things
that interest you the truth is passion
is Just Energy
passionate about something it means
you're energized when you do it so let's
reverse engineer this and let's just
yourself a simple question
allow yourself to explore things that
energize you you my friend will start to
find the clues about what it is that you
should and could be doing because all
the research says that if you're doing
something that you like if you're doing
something that you're curious about
you're only going to enjoy it you're
going to be really good at it because if
you like doing it you'll spend more time
doing it which means you're going to get
better at it you know sometimes when the
dream is so big the fact that it's so
big becomes paralyzing because you think
about where you are right now and you
think holy cow that thing that I really
want I don't even like how do you even
start when the dream is so big
so here's what we're going to do today
we're going to shrink it down because
you know me I am all about Simplicity
I'm all about making sure that the
advice works for you because if it
doesn't work for you you're not going to
do it and I'm all about switching how
you think about things
huh making this smaller and making it
something that I'm learning about rather
than doing and launching and hmm
that somehow thinking about it
differently frees up the ability to get
started if I get you to start doing that
and you do this every day for 10 or 15
minutes which you absolutely can guess
what's going to happen you're going to
feel momentum you're going to feel like
you're working on it you're going to
meet people that are interested in it
you're going to learn things that are
going to lead to the next thing that you
need to learn and you will have mastered
the art of getting started and by doing
something a little bit every day you're
also going to master the art of
continuing to keep going and from there
it'll snowball I promise you I promise
you you see you're only ever running
against yourself there's room for all of
us there's room for you to do the same
thing there's room for you to write that
book there's room for you to do those
makeup tutorials there's room for you to
launch that restaurant there's room for
you to start your singing lessons
there's room for you to write that song
it is normal and it is going to happen
to you all the time that you're going to
see people that seem to block out the
sun whenever they make an announcement
because they're that pig and that
amazing I don't want you to allow
yourself to shrink when somebody else is
doing something that is similar to what
you want to do refresh your routine
refresh your routine why is this
important I'll tell you why that's this
is important because there is so much
science that talks about the power of
your morning routine and there's also so
much noise out there about the morning
routine and I don't know about you but
when I read all these articles about the
power of a morning routine I'm typically
reading them by some male influencer who
clearly doesn't have children yet or
some male CEO no no offense to the dudes
but all of the Articles out there tend
to be written by guys that have two and
a half hours before work starts to
somehow drink mushroom tea and meditate
and go to yoga and exercise and drink
Bulletproof Coffee and sit in an
infrared sauna and I don't know what
planet these people live on but they
clearly don't have children or a job
they need to get to at eight o'clock in
the morning and not to make anyone wrong
I'm being realistic I'm being realistic
about the fact that you need a morning
routine but you need one that works for
you and for where you are in your life
in this season you see I had a morning
routine that used to take me 30 to 40
minutes
last year when I had more time I've had
a morning routine that took an hour when
I had time and the ability to go for a
jog in the morning I'd incorporate that
in the morning routine do you realize
that my morning routine right now
has been responsible for helping me curb
my anxiety it's responsible for why I'm
so successful and I'm able to be
productive my morning routine 10 minutes
long that's it it's 10 minutes long
because that's what works for me in this
season of my life because you made it
this far in a video I want to celebrate
you most people start and don't finish
most people never actually follow
through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome
if you want another amazing Mel
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there when you hit a moment in your
life or your work or your family where
you feel very overwhelmed
one of the most important things to not
do is an over-scheduled entrepreneur
cannot be creative